のこの声ホッケーこいつがノコノコとプレイ大会で内心ホッケーゲームコーナーが吹く
4プレイ代がなくてもヘイリーの場所ならどこでも遊べる
こうねー
マジやばくねこれマジやばくねこれあの僕見つけた瞬間や当てると思いましたちょっと
開けてみます
これがあのあれここに本題ですなあーこちらのコーラ付随この巧妙な空気声出てるよね
こうやって僕土地あるわけなんですけども普通や ok ってほど床から空気が出てて
それでこれがちょっとこういって植えてつはこうやって出来るんですけど
の言葉
日本型はこの本第二審から空気が出ていますは一般家庭でもできるエアホッケーなん
ですよこれ
丁稚入れてみますかー
ドライバーネイルはドライバーはやダニーだわーんっ
ああああああ
何遺体のドライバーで大切ですがさあ手に入れてみる贈与
ok 入れて締め直すと ok 前が知りたいなそもそもこれがどれくらい行くかって
いうところねちょっとオンにしてみますはい
[拍手]
[音楽]
を
おおーー
大まあすごいけど位
毛布とどんな作りの平面状だったらこれでこうやってもええホッケーができるという
仕組みになっております
これ使えるなこれ確か3月など去年のクリスマスぐらいだったんですけども沢山欲し
いって思っちゃって頑張ってくれたくまとりました
を見て言ってなくて本当にもうね色んな店入った静岡のお店東京を見て色々聞いたん
ですけど全然売ってなくてアーマーゾーンを支え
ネットショッピングを使い本なんと全力を尽くしてこれだけ集めましたはい
はぁ
いっ
これ以上無理だったこれじゃ無理だったアマゾンとかもなんかお1人様10個までとは
個数制限かかってて
何そんなにレアなとか思いながらちょっと買ったんですけどに中国集めるのでかなり
苦労しました今回はこれを使って古くじゃないですかこのコーラがこの頃から空気が出
て行くということはこれはたくさん集めればととショル受けるんじゃないかなと思い
まして産んだって風
行くじゃん
ホラー
これだけたくさんのコーラがあればそれの上に古木が乗るとひょっとしたらウケるん
じゃないんだと思いまして
でもなぁ
もっと言わ買ったのリーダーやることに意味があります設けなかったら受けなかったら
もういいんですよ失敗したら失敗車で僕もたくさんの絵ホッケーで遊びます山
関いい母と行くぜっ
あーはっはっは
ます
た
th
パッ貼ってくれたプレゼント増えたぴゅっどぴゅっと増えて打ち抜くれたわー
ええええアップでダメダメないほど投げるんだよ
シルクとっている本当に
たいときデコーダ全部に電通入れました大量のことを打つ部分と高覧25コントの言葉
やホッケーのシールが出てきました
チーズが使わないないって全部電気つけてみましょう
はいいいえ
全然これああ4つだよこれ全部電源は入ってます結局術
ああああああ
ちょっとぞっと持って待って待って
rar
28中でこれからこの上に1雷&ギターを置きます2
ギターんおいている時かどうかですねちょっとやってみましょう
はぁ
というわけで
正直もうね1個目が電気つけた瞬間も無理ってわかっていましたパワー不足ですまあ
乗れない室は逆に何なら乗れるんだろうこういう次回ペルとかが濡れるのかね
混ぜてみます
バー
[拍手]
ええええええ
はぁ
me
dea
re だった
th